çok
ama çok önemli Eğer sizlerle bugün
özellikle konuşmak istediğim konu
canlılarla ortak yaşamla alâkadar
buradaki bahsettiğimiz canlılar Sadece
evli dostlarımızla alâkadar değil birçok
canlı türü ile aslında bir ortak yaşam
içerisindeyiz en çok ortak yaşam
içerisinde bulunduğumuz kişiler
ebeveynlerimiz mesela
doğal olarak bunlarla alakalı uyum
sağlamak Benim tabi beni ilgilendiren
kısım insanlar olan kısım değil de daha
küçük hayvanlarla olan ilgili kısmı size
birazcık daha anlatacağım
Şimdi öncelikle bir canlıyı hayatımıza
koyduğumuzda o canlıyla alâkadar bütün
standartları gerçekleştirmeniz gerekiyor
buradaki standartlardan kastım Mesela
bir alt yetiştirmek istiyorsanız
adınızın bir büyük Başkada küçükbaş
yetiştir abone olursanız ağırlığınızı
bir köpeğiniz varsa bir büyük bir
köpeksin özellikle bahçemizin olması
Yani onun koşabileceği gezebileceği
özgür bir alanı olması bir Kediniz varsa
kedinin evin içerisinde Özgür yaşamın
olabileceği orta kısımları hepsini
halletmeniz Gerekiyor bazen çok minik
bir yanlış vardır evcil dostlarımızla
alâkadar yani sadece mamasını suyunu
koyarak bu canlıların yaşam kalitelerini
yaşam standartlarını sağladığını
düşünüyor insanlar bu çok büyük bir
yanlış çok yanlış bir algı Açıkçası bu
yani sokakta mamayı nasıl oluyor yani
biz burada önünde mama koyuyoruz biz
suyunu veriyoruz falan tarzında sadece
ihtiyaçlarının bulduğu düşünülmesi çok
çok açıkçası yanlış bir durum Çünkü her
şeyden önce bir laf vardır bir cümle
vardır Biz de bizim Cami yanımızda
hayvanların Ağzı var ama Yok yok doğal
olarak onların sıkıntılarını
şikayetlerini anlayabilmeye çalışmak Bu
gerçekten çok çok önemli bir gayet bir
ortak yaşam çerçevesine giren en büyük
Araf en büyük konu ise bunun dahilinde
olmuş oluyor Onları anlamaya çalışmaktan
kasıp Hayat standartlarını yaşatmakla
başlıyor Mesela bir kedi evinizin
içerisinde aldığımızda Siz zaten kedinin
doğal yaşamından alıyorsunuz Bir onu
Doğal yaşamı tamamen dışarıdan ev
ortamında doğru dönüştürüyor sunuz bir
kere yani O kedinin
doğal yaşamında Özgür olarak yapabildiği
şeyleri ona katmamız gerekiyor Mesela
oynamak istediğini ikili zarfları
özellikle bilir Onların bir şeyler var
Eşref saatleri var benimkileri de gece
benim üç tane kedim var onlarda gecelere
kudurur açıkçası 10.00 gibi ile iki
arasında 00 böyle evin içerisinde koştur
oynarlar bir değil Onun dışında
genellikle yatmayı ve kendini sevdirmeye
tercih ederler Tabi bu enerjilerini Ata
bilmeleri için onlardan oyuncaklarının
olması sevdiği oyuncaklarını almamız
gerekiyor basit bir top Lazer Pointer
şeklinde değil durur yani onun sevdiği
şey bulabilmek Mesela yani bizler için
de geçerli Herkes bu çocukken böyle
insanlar yetiştirirken empoze edilen
bazı şeyler var kız çocuklarına
bebeklere erkek çocuklarını arabalar
verilir bir çocuk hangisini sevmeye
başlarsak onu oyuncak olarak tercih
etmesi daha mantıklı bir seçenek olacağı
gibi bu Tıpkı kendiniz için de geçerli
yani Şuna çok şahit oluyorum mesela
bazen böyle fotoğraflarda çok görüyoruz
et hasta sahibimiz gidiyor böyle kedi
evi alıyor böyle çok tatlı çok Minnoş
bir kedi mi Ondan sonra evi kurduktan
sonra kutu yanında duruyor kedi Kutunun
içerisinde yani o ev kullanmayı asla
tercih bu doğal olarak Hamit Bu da
canlının hangi oyuncağı sevdiğini tercih
olarak göstermesinin sebebi nedir Tabii
burada şeye dikkat etmek gerekiyor yani
her oyuncak iyi bir oyuncak değildir her
yer onun sevdiği şeyler onun için
yararlı olabileceği anlamına gelmiyor
işte ortak yaşam da buradan muktedir
oluyor diğer bir örnek köpeklerden
bahsedersek mesela
köpeklerde en çok hasta sahiplerinin en
çok böyle uyardım yani burada en iyi bir
köpek sahiplenmek isteyen
arkadaşlarımız varsa onları da bu
uyarılır hangi türden köpeği nedenle
ihtiyaçlar olduğunu çok iyi anlamamız
gerekiyor Yani İstanbul'da şehrin
merkezinde Kangal beslemek istiyorum
diyen bir kişi yani Kangal bir gün
içerisinde on kilometre 15 kilometre
yürüyen Koç Bu bir canlı bu koşulları
sağlayacaksınız Antal Hımbıl bir
kavgamız olur Normal fizyolojik
davranışlarında bulunmayan canlılar için
bu sefer anormal hastalıklar göz önünde
olabilir bu tarz durumlar çıkabilir
büyük ırk köpek sahiplenmek istiyorsanız
kesinlikle ve kesinlikle günlük
yürüyüşlerinin sağlanması gerekiyor
şimdi konuyu biraz daha ortak yaşam
çerçevesine çekmeye başlarsak Yani işin
içerisinde biraz daha empati kurmaya
delersek bir Labrador ya da bir Golden
en çok karşımıza çıkanlar golden köpek
ırkları olarak bir Google'ın ihtiyacı
Evet Gezmek konuşmak gülmek eğlenmek bir
insana mesela
Psikolojik sıkıntı yaşayan Asosyal bir
birey şüphe ile beraber dışarı
çıkmasıyla onun sosyalleşmesine yardımcı
olur Demek ki ortak yaşam buradan aynı
zamanda Fayda ne oluyor veyahut
sağlıksız günlük yürüyüş yapmak zorunda
olan bir bireyin yani kilo vermeye
çalışan ve örnek veriyorum karaciğerinde
yağlanma var Karaciğer yağlanması ve
doktorunu kesinlikle Diyet ve spor
verdiği bir hastasının yürüyüş yapmasına
teşvik bir aynı zamanda köpeği ile
beraber tatlı bir yürüyüş yapması işte
empatik kurmamız gereken nokta da burada
Aziz Nesin'in çok güzel bir kitabı var
Herkese okumasını tavsiye ederim hayvan
değil geçmediğim yani burada hayvan
deyip geçmemek onu bir canlı olduğunu
unutmamak gerekiyor açıkçası biz bu
yayına konuşmadan önce yayının geldiği
tarihte biraz manidar oldu hayvanları
koruma yasası mecliste görüşülüyor bu
hafta Umarım bu çocukların bu canlıların
bunlar için en güzel en mantıklı ve en
uyarlanabilir Evet
Ee maddelerin yasalaşması Çok çok doğru
olur Çünkü maalesef oğlu kanunumuz mal
olarak görüyorlardı Yani bir herhangi
bir insanın bir canlıya bir çöpe zarar
vermesiyle bir arabaya zarar vermesi
arasında hiçbir fark yoktu yasa olarak
kabahatler kanunu çerçevesinde idi Ve
bunun karşılığı sadece Ara cezasıydı
şimdi bu Prosedür tamamen değişmeye
başlayacak ve onlar Artık mal olarak
değil onlar artık cam olarak
yasalarımızda ibraz edilecek ve bu da
açıkçası yıllardır beklediğimiz bir ya
saydığı umarın en güzel en sağlıklı
şekilde olur ortak yaşama alâkadar biraz
daha şimdi bizim en çok şehirde yaşayan
insanlar için karşımıza çıkabilen şeyler
genellikle kediler ve köpekler ve
muhabbet kuşlarıyla Yani tabii Bağlar'da
dahili evcil kuşlarla alâkadar şeyler
oluyor ama
bu bu Kürdistan'da yaşayan insanların da
atlarla eş çiçeklerle ineklerle ve yani
daha doğrusu sığırlarla ve
koyun ve kişilerle de bir iç içe bir
ortak yaşam durumu söz konusu olabiliyor
burada canlının sadece ortak yaşamı bunu
ekstra katkıları Bize bizim beslene
bileceğimiz ve onlardan
faydalanabileceğiniz ekstra ürünler
olmuş oluyor Ama bu biraz daha tehlikeli
bir durum yaratabiliyor yani onların cam
olarak değil de onların mal olarak
görmek konusunda Çünkü besi sığırcılığı
üzerine yetiştirilmiş bir sınır belli
bir noktadan sonra kesime gidip
insanların tüketimleri sunmak üzere
hazırlandığından dolayı bu biraz algısı
farklılığı yaratabiliyor açıkçası ama
ülkemizdeki Çiftçiler Bu konuda
gerçekten çok şeyler çok duygusal var
birkaç defa üniversite hayatında yaşa Bu
üniversitede iken okulda inkar veteriner
için olarak çalışırken
birkaç tane hasta sahibinin ineğinin
kötü olduğunu ya kişisinin kötü kötü
olduğunu duyunca onlara gerçekten bal
gözüyle değil can gözüyle bak bana çok
şahit oldu doğal olarak bizim de bu
konuda bu canlılarla ortak yaşam
konusunda aldığımızı biraz daha
değiştirmemiz gerekiyor diğer bir
bahsetmek istediğim konu ise tamamı yere
ekosistemde alâkadar dünyaya çok kötü
bir zarar veriyoruz açıkçası yani
dünyada en sevilmeyen bir organizma
olarak yani birçok şırdan canlılar var
yoloji den bilirsiniz
organizma olarak Bence Dünya'ya en çok
zarar veren canlılar var Tamam yani
İnsanlar bir parazitler bile çok fazla
zarar veriyoruz yaşadığımız yere
tamamı yen Mesela bu son o kadar
gördüğümüz müsilaj olayı buna çok net
bir şekilde mesela indiriyor ortak
yaşadığımız Deniz beraber
beslendiğimiz denizi maalesef
çıkar uğruna ki getir pozisyona geldik
Sera gazlarının inat da hala
kullanılmasıyla beraber
barros Ozon tabakasına zarar vererek
tamamı yeni küresel ısınmaya doğru
sürüklenen küresel ısınmanın etkilerini
arttırmaya devam ediyoruz Nitekim
Kanada'da Bu yaşanan son olaylar
karşımıza çıkmıştı ama şu unutmamamız
unutmamamız lazım
Doğan'a acımasızdır yani daha doğrusu
yani
verdiği karşılık gerçekten çok sert
olabilir Bunu doğal afetlerden de
görebiliyoruz defalarca bir çok canlının
yaşamını yitirmesi
bu başlangıç çok çok kötü olaylarla
karşı karşıya kaldık buradaki canlılar
Sadece insanlar değil yani
İnsanların en büyük özelliği Serebral
korteks dediğimiz düşünsen zekâsının
kuvvetli olması bana göre açıkçası insan
türü yeryüzündeki en önemli en kıymetli
Türk değil yeryüzündeki en önemli en
kıymetli tür diye bir şey yoktur Her
canlı kıymetlidir Her canlı değerlidir
ve hepsinin bir yaşam hakkı vardır doğal
olarak bu ortak paydada buluşup
dünyamızı güzelleştirmek de tamamen
bizim elimizde
bazen şu bu konularla alâkadar karşıma
çıkan en büyük
şeyler söyle en büyük sözler bu şu
oluyor yani ben Ben sadece ben yapsam ne
kadar değişebilir ki yani bir kişi bile
dünyada çok büyük şeyler değiştirebilir
Yani bir seçimler Bu Bir Oyun nelere
kadir olabildiğine bile şahit olmuş bir
insanım açıkçası
Fanatik Fenerbahçeli yani Aziz Yıldırım
bir oyuncak araba için 20 yıl başkanı
Olmuştu yani bir kişi bile dünyada çok
büyük şeyler değiştirebilir Yeter ki
Evet siz kırılmasın Yeter ki hiçbir
şekilde
yüreğimizdeki Ateş sönmesin Siz bir kişi
ile başlayıp
önce kendinizi değiştirerek sonra
etrafınızdakileri değiştirerek sonu
çevremizdeki çişleri değiştirerek bir
kişiden çok daha fazla bir kalabalık
olabilirsiniz yani
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk'ün yetiştirdiği
genç neslin özellikle biraz sizi
arkadaşlar zevk kuşağı olarak
tanımlıyorlar bu benim çok hoşuma
gitmiyor aday ediyorlardı
Ama bu yeni gelen kuşak çok daha
birleşti çok daha akıllı bir şak doğal
olarak
her şeyi ölçme tartma konusunda çok daha
efektif sonuçlar
alınabiliyor sizlerden yani
yaşına bakmaksızın aklına bakılan
insanların sayısı gerçekten atmaya
başladı
bu nesil olarak sizlerle gurur duyuyorum
açıkçası araştırmacı olmanız
ve herşeyden önce çevreci olmanızı daha
çok tercih ediyorum bir bunu alâkadar
yapabileceğimiz her şey dünyamızda
alâkadar olduğundan dolayı aile sadece
kendimize değil ailemize çevremize ve
dünyamızdan çok büyük haklar ve
sağlayabiliriz ve ortak yaşam olarak
değerlendirebileceğimiz konular açıkçası
benim anlatabilecek lerim Şimdilik bu
kadar evcil dostlarımızdan başlayıp
dünyamıza kadar iç dünyamızda küçük
dünyamızdan küresel Dünya ne anlatmak
istediklerim bu kadar
bir herkesten Eğer bir isteğim olursa
yani kabul edilecek bir isteğin varsa bu
hakkımı ise çevresini düşünen bilinçli
gençler olmanız
bile iyi bir açıkçası bunu da kabul
ederseniz müteşekkir olurum
Ne anlamadım
[Müzik]